So anyway,
uh,
to get launched on today's topic.
Uh,
well,
obviously we confront one of the more formidable figures on our syllabus.
A person who,
uh,
who recently passed away,
and who in his last years and into the present has had a kind of second life as
a person who in his later work,
uh,
then that all repudiate his earlier thoughts or indeed his earlier style,
but nevertheless did,
uh,
begin to apply is central central aspects of his thinking to ethical and
political issues.
And so he,
uh,
and a number of other writers,
like for example,
the Italian philosopher,
Georgie or Gambon,
uh,
are the figures who we identify with what's called the s called the ethical
turn.
In thinking about texts,
literature and other matters,
uh,
that is very much of the current moment.
And so,
so dairy does reputation and the tendency of people interested in theory to read
him is alive and well today about the materials that we're a reading in this,
uh,
in this,
sequence of lectures for the sequence of lectures,
uh,
date back much earlier.
Uh,
the essay that you read in its entirety for today,
structured sign and play in the language of the human sciences was delivered on
the occasion of a conference about the sciences of man,
uh,
at Johns Hopkins University in 1966.
It was an event,
uh,
that was really meant to be a kind of coronation of Claude Levy Strauss whose
work had burst upon the scene only a few years earlier.
A Levy Strauss was there.
He gave a talk.
He was in the audience and dairy does essay was widely taken,
uh,
far from being a coronation of a Levy Strauss as a kind of de thronging of Levy
Strauss.
And I have to tell you that why they stylists who is still alive,
a very old man,
um,
uh,
expresses great bitterness in his old age about what he takes to be the
displacement of the importance of his own work,
uh,
by what happened,
subsequently.
Uh,
and what happened subsequently,
um,
can I think,
be traced to dairy does lecture one of the complications,
one of the million complications of thinking about this lecture and about dairy
does work in general.
And for that matter about deconstruction is indeed,
uh,
whether or not it really to what extent it really is a significant departure
from the work of structuralism.
There is a self consciousness in the thinking about structure that we find in
many places in Levy Strauss that Derrida freely acknowledges in his essay,
uh,
again and again and again.
He quotes Levis Strauss in confirmation of his own arguments only then in a way
to turn on him by pointing out that there's something even in what he's saying
there that he hasn't quite thought through.
So it is not anything like,
even as one reads it,
um,
in retrospect,
uh,
a wholesale repudiation or even a really a very devastating critique of Levy
Strauss.
He,
Derrida I think freely acknowledges in this essay the degree to which he is
standing on Levy Strauss's shoulders.
But in any case,
this extraordinary event did,
however,
in the imaginations of people thinking about theory and the West did,
uh,
tend to bring about a sense of almost overnight revolution from the
preoccupation we had in the mid sixties were structuralism to the subsequent
preoccupation we had,
uh,
throughout the 70s and into the early eighties with deconstruction.
Uh,
and,
uh,
so,
and Derrida was of course,
a central figure in this.
He was here at Yale as a visitor in the spring for many years.
Uh,
he influenced a great many,
uh,
people whose work is still current,
throughout the United States and elsewhere.
Uh,
he,
after that,
[inaudible] had a comparable arrangement with the University of California at
Irvine and his influence there continued,
uh,
a key figure,
um,
whom,
uh,
many of us remember,
from the,
uh,
period.
His period at Yale,
uh,
as a galvanizing presence.
Uh,
it was the,
the idea that there was a,
what was called by one critic,
a hermeneutical mafia at Yale,
uh,
arose largely from the presence of Derrida together with,
with our own Paul Man,
uh,
and more loosely connected with them.
Uh,
Jeffrey Hartman and Harold Bloom,
and also a scholar named Jay Hillis Miller,
who's departure for the University of California.
Irvine a resulted also in dairy,
does decision to go there and be with Miller rather than to continue to stay
here.
Uh,
but that was,
that was the Yale School,
the so called the El School.
Um,
and it generated a extraordinary influenced to some extent,
but well beyond its influence and atmosphere of hostility,
which,
uh,
had in many ways to do,
I think with what might,
what might still be called the crisis in the humanities as it is widely
understood,
uh,
by,
state legislators,
by boards of trustees,
um,
as somehow or another something needing to be overcome,
backed away from forgotten in the development of the humanities,
uh,
in academia.
Um,
and the reasons for this,
uh,
we can only imply,
I think probably in the context of a course of this nature,
uh,
but are nevertheless a fascinating and will recur,
as we think not just about a deconstruction itself,
but,
uh,
about,
about the sorts of thinking that it has influenced.
Now you've now read some dairy dot.
You've read all of one essay and you've read part of another defect holes and
you found it very difficult.
And indeed,
in addition to finding it very difficult,
you've probably said,
why does he have to write like that?
In other words,
yeah,
okay.
He's difficult,
but he's,
isn't he making it more difficult than it needs to be?
You say to yourself,
I've never seen pros like this.
You say,
I mean,
this is ridiculous.
Why doesn't he just say one thing at a time?
You might also want to say,
uh,
well,
of course it's all deliberate on his part.
And the idea is that deconstruction is as a thought process,
precisely a kind of evasive dance whereby one doesn't settle for distinct
positions for any sort of idea that can be understood as governed.
And this is what structure sign in play is all above that can be understood as
governed by a blanket term.
What Derrida often calls a transcendental signified,
we'll have much more to say about this,
but dairy does prose style.
It's kind of crab like sideways movement around an argument is meant,
uh,
as rigorously as it can to avoid a seeming to derive itself from some definite
concept because of course deconstruction is precisely the deconstruction of the
grounds whereby we suppose are thinking can be derived from one or another.
Definite concept.
Also this to be kept in mind.
And this is of course one of the key distinctions between Derrida and demonn.
We'll have more to say about distinctions between them.
On Tuesday,
I'll also to be captain mind Derrida is not a literary theorist though he
sometimes does talk about texts that we call literary very often does.
Uh,
nevertheless,
dairy,
dairy does position and the logic of that position suggest that we can't really
reliably discriminate among genres.
In other words,
we can't use genre either as a blanket term and therefore he is one of these,
one of the people,
one of the most influential people in persuading us that there's no such thing
as literature,
legal text,
a theological text,
philosophical text,
scientific taxed.
There is discourse and that,
uh,
to think about,
to think about the field of texts is to think about something which is full of
difference.
Who,
needless to say it's the central word and Derrida,
but which is nevertheless not classifiable or categorizable.
And so for that reason,
um,
we can't really say Derrida is specifically a literary theorist.
Now,
I've been talking so far about difficulty and confusion,
but uh,
in view of the fact that we,
you know,
we're all in a state of tension about this.
I'm in,
I'm in a state of tension about it too.
Let me remind us that we've already been doing deconstruction and that much of
what's problematic in reading dairied I really has already been explained.
I mean,
let's begin with a kind of warmup sheet,
um,
which,
which we can use,
which we can anchor.
And these little drawings I've made now,
no,
I don't think it,
I mean obviously you look at these drawings and you say,
Aha,
that's the vertical axis,
right?
Um,
and of course,
once we get to feminism,
feminism will have certain ideas of its own about the vertical axis.
Uh,
and we will be,
and we will be getting into that when the time comes.
But in the meantime,
you know,
the Eiffel Tower is a wonderful way of showing the degree to which the vertical
axis is virtual.
That is to say that if you ever saw a dotted line standing upright,
it's the Eiffel Tower.
There's nothing in it.
It's empty,
it's transparent,
you know,
and there's a wonderful Annika and yet somehow or another,
if you're at the top of it,
in the,
in,
in the viewing station at the top of the Eiffel Tower,
suddenly all of Paris is organized at your feet.
That is to say it's a wonderful access of combination that you're looking at.
It is just there with its landmarks,
not,
you know,
instead of having the same kind of status,
is that what you're standing on?
But rather just in a kind of row as the key signs as it were of the skyline of
Paris.
So you get milk Notradame,
arc de Triomphe and so on,
you know,
all sort of lined up in a row.
And there it is,
uh,
Geeta Bopa saw,
in a famous anecdote,
uh,
who complained rather bitterly about this and he says,
according to roll embarked in an essay called the Eiffel Tower.
Moba saw often ate at the restaurant in the tower up here someplace,
oven ate at the restaurant in the tower,
even though he didn't particularly like the food,
it's the only place he said where I don't have to see it.
In other words,
if as so Sarah says,
once again,
we put both feet squarely on the ground of the Eiffel Tower.
All right?
If we do that,
we're liberated from the idea that somehow or another it's a governing presence.
If we're actually there,
we no longer have to worry about the way it organizes everything around it into
a kind of rigorous on folding pattern.
You know,
after all,
you know,
there's a very real sense in which the iPhone,
we infer the Eiffel Tower from its surroundings.
It's built in the 19th century.
It's by no means causative of the skyline of Paris.
It's something that comes in belatedly,
just as long comes in,
belatedly with,
with relation to speech.
You know,
the Eiffel Tower is a,
is a virtuality that organizes things as one might say,
arbitrarily,
sort of as a reflection on these same ideas.
You get the famous poem of Wallace Stevens,
I'm sure you'll recognize this as Stevens,
is jar.
Uh,
but I will quickly quote to you the poem.
I placed a jar in Tennessee and round,
it was upon a hill.
It made the Slovenly wilderness surround that hill.
The wilderness rose up to it and sprawled around.
No longer wild.
As Derrida would say,
the center limits free play,
right?
The wilderness rolls up to it and sprawled around.
No longer wild.
The jar was round upon the ground and tall and have a port in air.
It took dominion everywhere.
The Jar was gray and bear.
It did not give of bird or Bush like nothing else in Tennessee.
In other words,
it is arbitrarily placed in the middle of the free play of the natural world,
a free play which is full of which is full of of reproductive exuberance,
full of a kind of joyous excess,
which is part of what dairy does.
Talking about when he talks about what's left over the surplusage of the sign,
the supplementaries [inaudible] of the sign.
There's an orgasmic element in the in,
in what Derrida has in mind so that when he speaks of the seminal adventure of
the traits toward the end of,
toward the end of your essay,
you want to put some pressure on that word salmon oil.
Well,
in any case,
the jar is just arbitrarily in the middle of that organizing everything without
participating in the nature of anything.
It is,
in other words,
a center which is outside the structure of center,
which is not a center.
And we'll come back to that in a minute.
Now,
the Twin Towers,
uh,
and I first started using this example,
decades 2001,
the twin towers have a kind of poignancy in path those today,
uh,
that they would not have had.
Um,
and,
but,
but what they suggest is,
uh,
in a,
in a way today,
which,
which overwhelms us with grief.
What they suggest is the ephemerality of the vertical axis.
The twin towers had the same function in New York that the Eiffel Tower had in
Paris.
Uh,
it was a wonderful place from which to see the city,
a wonderful place from which to feel that everything was organized at its feet.
Uh,
it really there,
there's a,
there's a very fine essay about the twin towers again,
long before 2001 by Michelle decept toe,
which makes this argument,
uh,
in sustained form.
I recommend it to you,
but in any case,
it's another example,
uh,
that we can take from our experience of the uneasy sense.
We may have that to infer a spatial moment from which the irreducibly temporal
nature of experience is derived to infer a moment from the fact of this
experience as a necessary cause of it is always problematic and always
necessarily must,
as Derrida would say,
put this sense of a spacial full presence of everything there at once in
systematic order as Derrida,
I would say,
must put that under eraser.
In other words,
in a certain sense,
you can't do without it.
Dairy Derrida never really claims that you can do without it.
If you want to get a sense of structure,
you've got to have some sort of inference of this nature.
But at the same time it,
he had had better be in quotes because it is always tenuous if femoral dubious
even in even as to its existence and necessarily needs to be understood in that
way.
All right,
now other ways in which we've already,
uh,
already been involved in the subject matter,
for that you,
that you've been reading today.
Uh,
take a look at page nine,
21,
uh,
a couple of passages in which is straw in which Derrida is quoting a Levy
Strauss on the nature of myth.
And here's where a having quoted you,
these two passages from Levy Strauss.
Here's where I'll return just for a moment to Levy Strauss's analysis of the
Oedipus myth and show you how it is that Derrida is both benefiting from what
Levy Strauss has said and ultimately able to criticize.
Levy Strauss is position bottom of the left hand column nine 21,
an opposition to epistemic discourse.
That is to say the kind of discourse which has,
uh,
some principle or transcendental signified or blanket term as its basis.
In other words,
something,
uh,
which in a given moment makes it possible for all knowledge to flow from it in
opposition to epistemic discourse,
structural discourse on myths,
mythological discourse must itself be Mytho morphic.
It must have the form of that of which it speaks and love.
And Derrida then says,
this is what Levy Strauss himself says in the following passage taken from one
of Levis Strauss,
his most famous books,
the Ra.
And the cook and the cooked.
I just want to quote the end of it.
The middle of the right hand column still on page nine,
21 levy Strauss says in wanting to imitate the spontaneous movement of mythical
thought,
my enterprise itself too brief and too long,
has yet to yield to its demands,
has,
has had to yield it to its demands and respect.
It's rhythm.
Thus is this book on myths itself and in its own way a myth.
In other words,
here's a moment where I live is drives is admitting something about his own
work,
which he is not admitting in his analysis of the Oedipus myth in the essay from
structural anthropology that you read.
Uh,
last time.
What love is jobs is saying here is that his approach to myth is itself only
aversion of the myth.
That is to say it participates in the mythic way of thinking about things.
It uses what in the,
uh,
structural anthropology essay he calls MyThemeShop or gross constituent units of
thought.
Uh,
it deploys and manipulates those gross constituent units of thought in the ways
that we saw.
But notice what Levy Strauss is saying in that essay as opposed to in the past.
It's Derrida has just quoted,
he says,
this form of the meth is scientific.
One of the versions that I have made use of to arrive at this scientific
conclusion is,
for example,
Freud's version of the Oedipus meth and other,
it's Freud,
Sophocles.
All the other versions I have at my disposal have equal merit as versions,
but none of them is a,
is a transcendental signified none of them as a blanket term.
None of them is the causal explanation or meaning of the myth.
The meaning of the myth is discoverable only in my science.
Now,
of course,
Freud himself thought he was a scientist and his reading of the myth was also
supposed to be scientific.
What was Freud's reading of the myth about two or one?
It was,
in other words,
about the problem of incest,
the problem of the over determination of blood relations and the under
determination of blood relations.
It was a thorough examination of that problematic,
uh,
leading to the conclusion that that's what the myth was about.
In other words,
Levy Strauss,
his conclusions are already anticipated in Freud.
And furthermore,
what is Levy Strauss doing?
He's denying the influence of Freud,
right?
It's my myth,
not his myth,
right?
Which of course is precisely what happens in the prime will hoard.
It is a perfect instance of the Oedipus complex.
Levy Strauss is repudiating the father,
uh,
and in repudiating the father showing himself to fall into the very mythic
pattern that Freud had been the first to analyze.
Okay.
So when you say there what you're doing is scientific in a context of this sort,
you are making yourself vulnerable.
And the moments in this essay in which Derrida is criticizing Levy Strauss are
those moments in which Levy Strauss has unguardedly said something on the order
of my work is scientific.
So,
but,
but there are lots of occasions and he always quotes Levy Strauss to this effect
when Levy Strauss is not saying that when Levy Strauss is conceding that his
work,
that is to say his viewpoint disappears unstably into the thing viewed.
All right.
Now also take a look at it because we've been doing this to take a look at page
nine 17 the lefthand column where Derrida is talking not about Levy Strauss but
about,
so sir and here he's talking about the nature of the sign and he's concerned,
very much concerned about this relationship between the concept and the sound
image,
which is to say the signified and the signifier that is the basis of the science
of so sir,
that is to say the relationship between the pair in the that's involved in the
pairing of signified and signifier is the basis the cornerstone of the science
of so sir.
So here's what a little more than halfway down the left hand column.
Page nine 17 Derrida has to say about that.
He says,
the signification sign has always been comprehended and determined in its sense
as sign of signifier,
referring to a signified signifier.
Different from its signify.
If one erases the radical difference between signifier and signified.
It is the word signifier itself,
which ought to be abandoned as a metaphysical concept,
a metaphysical concept,
which is to say that a transcendental signified,
in other words,
the idea that a,
that the concept in some sense generates the sa the signifier,
right?
Which is which,
which is the basis of,
so Sutter's thinking about this,
but,
and here's where I come back to that example that I already gave you,
but with a question mark next to it when I was talking about,
so sure.
Suppose I think of the relationship between quotes signified and quotes,
signifier as the relationship between two terms.
Because after all,
you know,
one way of signifying the concept tree is to write the word tree and put
quotation marks about it.
So if I take away the quotation marks,
all I have is the word with no indication that it's a concept.
Notice that this is now a relationship,
which Jakobsen would call metal lingual.
It what?
What's,
what it suggested is tree is another word for our boar and other,
it's a relationship not between a signified and signifier,
but between a signifier and a signifier.
So that the binarism of the relationship is broken down and we begin to
understand the combinatory structure of speech or writing as one signifier
leading to another,
uh,
s I think a signifier dairy dot says,
let's banish the word signifier.
But he and I will say,
let's banish the word signified.
I think a signifier added triggers by association as so sir would say it
triggers by association a subsequent successive signifier which triggers another
which triggers another.
And that's what gives us in the language of deconstruction what we call the
chain,
the signifying chain,
not an organizational pattern,
but an ever self replicating and self extending pattern.
Irreducibly linear and forward progressing through a sequence of temporal
associations.
One of the things that happens when you demystify the relationship between a
concept and a signifier or a sound image is that you're also dignify,
demystify the relationship between a set of associations with exists somehow
and,
and the way in which association actually takes place,
which is necessarily in time.
In other words,
you know,
if say if one signifier leads to another,
like history,
one damn thing after another speech is one damn signifier after another.
If one,
if one thing leads to another,
then that is actually the nature of the,
of,
of the associations that,
so Sarah has been talking about it in the first place,
but it doesn't exist in,
in a systemic space.
It exists in an unfolding time.
All right,
and this,
so,
so this then,
uh,
is,
are,
these are some of the implications of no longer being satisfied with the way in
which assign can be understood as a concept to which we attach belatedly a
signification,
a signifier.
What we have is we find is,
is a situation in which we find ourselves caught up in a stream of
signification,
all of which is in a certain sense there.
Before we came along and moved as down a stream by the way in which one
signifier succeeds another in ways that later on as we take up concepts like
supplement charity and defend Ross,
uh,
we can think of,
a little bit more in a little bit,
a little bit more precisely.
Okay,
so now,
finally,
then there's one other way in which dairy does essay from the very outset
confirms what we've been saying about the crisis of structuralism being the need
to deny ordinary understandings of genesis or cause in structuralism.
If something emerges,
it emerges from between two things.
That is to say it's not this and it's not this or that emerges as that which is
not this,
not this.
It doesn't,
in other words,
derive from an antecedent single cause as an effect.
It emerges on the other hand as difference within,
within a field.
Now,
that's what Derrida is talking about with extraordinary,
uh,
intensity of complication.
In the first paragraph of your essay,
page nine 15 left column,
first paragraph,
first word,
first words uttered at the famous conference at Johns Hopkins in 1966.
He says,
perhaps something has occurred in the history of the concept of structure that
could be called an event,
a then mom something which comes which emerges something which is there now and
wasn't there before.
That's the most problematic issue for structuralism when instructure lives and
thinks about how yesterday things were different from the way they are today.
It has to say yes today there was a certain sin,
chronic cross that cross section of data and today there's a slightly difference
in chronic cross section of data but structuralism is unable and furthermore,
much more importantly unwilling to say anything about how yesterday's data
turned into today's data and other,
it's to say anything about change.
It sees successive cross sections and it calls that history I'm anticipating
here and we'll come back to this in other contexts,
but it doesn't say one thing led to another.
It says one thing after another.
In my facetious reference,
uh,
to history as I've already given it to you.
Now,
this is what Derrida is deliberately struggling with in this first paragraph and
event,
quote unquote,
if this loaded word did not entail a meaning,
which it is precisely the function of structural or structuralist thought to
reduce or to suspect,
but let me use the term event,
quote unquote anyway,
employing it with caution and as if in quotation marks in this sense,
this event will have the exterior form of a rupture.
That is to say any emergence among things,
right?
A rupture pool,
you know the volcano,
the volcano parts,
and there you have lava right?
And event,
a rupture and a redoubling,
a redoubling in the sense something has happened as Bob Dylan would say,
something has happened,
but it's not something new.
It is in fact a replication of what was unbeknownst to you because Mr. Jones,
you don't know very much,
uh,
of what was unbeknownst to you.
They're always,
as Derrida says,
already something that emerges but is at the same time,
okay,
press at the same time presses on us.
It's status as having already been there,
always already been there.
All right.
So in all of these sorts of ways,
the critique,
this understanding structuralism as a problematic critique of genesis because
it's still very hard,
uh,
to grasp,
to accept the notion of not having been caused.
Why can't we say things were caused just for example,
the notion of the sign as a arbitrary relationship between,
uh,
a substratum of thought,
which is then somehow or another hooked on to a derivative series or,
or,
or a system of signifiers.
Uh,
the notion of,
uh,
getting outside of myth and being scientific and the notion that we can ascribe
reality to the vertical axis.
All of these ways of questioning the integrity,
the security within its skin of structuralism we have actually already
undertaken.
So I only want to suggest to you with this long preamble that much of the work
that lies before us is actually,
uh,
in the past and,
we have already accomplished now structure sign in play is a critique of
structured reality.
It's not just a critique of structuralism,
it's a street.
It's a,
it's a critique of the idea of anything that has a center,
which is at the same time and enabling causal principle and other words.
I look at a structure
and I say it has a center.
What do I mean by a center?
I mean a blanket term,
a guiding concept,
a transcendental signified,
something that explains the nature of the structure and something also as dairy
da says,
which allows for free play within the sub structure.
But at the same time,
you know,
the structure has this kind of boundary nature.
I mean it may be amoeboid but it still has boundaries,
right?
And so at the same time limits the free play within the structure and that's
like the new critics saying that a text has structure.
It has something that actually in the phenomenological tradition is called an
intentional structure.
You know what Kant calls it?
Purposiveness that is to say the way in which the thing is organized according
to some sort of guiding pattern,
but to speak of an intentional structure as a center is not at all the same
thing as to speak of an intending person or author or being or idea that brought
it into existence because that's extraneous,
that something prior.
That's genesis,
that's a cause.
The intending author in other words is outside.
Whereas we can argue that the intentional structure is inside.
But that's a problem.
I mean,
how do you get from uh,
an intending author to an intentional structure and back a center is both a
center and not a center.
As Derrida Madden maddeningly tells us it is both that which organizes a
structure and that which isn't really qualified to organize anything because
it's not in the structure.
It's outside the structure and something that imposes itself from without like a
cookie cutter on the structure.
All right.
And so this then is the,
is the,
is an introductory moment,
uh,
in dairy.
Does thinking about centers page on page nine,
16 in the lower left hand column,
he talks about the history of metaphysics as a history of successive appeals to
a center.
That is to say to a,
to some idea from which everything Daraja some genesis or other that can be
understood as responsible for everything that there is.
And the list is very cunningly put together.
This is bottom of the left hand column.
It's not necessarily chronological,
uh,
but at the same time it gives you a sense of successive metaphysical
philosophers thinking about first causes,
origins about that which determines about whatever it is that determines
everything else.
And I'll just take up the,
uh,
the uh,
list,
uh,
toward the end.
Transcendentality conscience,
consciousness or conscience,
God,
man and so forth.
Notice how,
notice that all though the list isn't strictly chronological man.
Nevertheless,
nevertheless does succeed.
God.
In other words,
he's thinking about the development of Western culture in the Middle Ages and to
some extent in the early modern period.
We live in a theocentric world.
Man is a,
understands himself insofar as he understands himself,
has man at all,
man,
understands himself as a product of divine creativity,
as something derived from God as one entity among all other entities,
uh,
who participate in and benefit from the divine presence.
But then of course the rise of enlightenment is also the rise of
anthropocentrism.
And by the time enlightenment is in full cry,
you get everybody from Blake to Mark's to Nisha saying,
not that God invented man,
but that man invented God.
Man has become the transcendental signified.
Everything derives now in this historical moment from human consciousness and
all concepts of whatever kind can be understood in that light.
But then of course he says,
having said,
man,
he says,
and so forth.
And I heard something,
something comes after man.
Man is in other words and historical moment,
there are lots of people who have pointed out to us that,
um,
before a certain period there was no such thing as man and in,
in,
in a variety of quite real senses.
After a certain moment in the history of culture,
there's also no such thing as man.
Uh,
and the argument Derrida is making about his,
about the emergence of his event is that a transcendental signified has actually
substituted itself for man.
In other words,
the world is no longer anthropocentric its linguistic.
Obviously the event that Derrida is talking about the emergence,
the rupture and event,
which makes a difference is the emergence of language.
On page nine 17,
the lefthand column,
Oh,
I'm sorry,
not uh,
take,
I take it back.
Uh,
what I really want to,
what I really want to talk about here is something that is on page nine 16,
the right hand column,
the moment of emergence,
the event.
In other words about halfway down was that in which language invaded the
universal problematic.
In other words,
that moment in which language displaced the previous transcendental signified,
which was man,
that in which in the absence of a center or origin,
everything became discourse provided.
We can agree on this word.
That is to say when everything became a system where the central signified the
original or transcendental signified is never absolutely present outside a
system of differences.
He's making a claim for language while racing it.
In other words,
he's,
he's painfully aware that language is just the new God,
the new man.
That and,
and many critiques of deconstruction take the form of saying,
ah,
that that deconstruction simply instrumentalize is language,
gives it agency,
gives it consciousness as though it were God or man and then pretends that it
isn't.
This is a,
this is a common response to deconstruction.
Derrida is aware of it in advance.
He says,
look,
I know we're running this risk and saying everything is language or if you will,
here everything is discourse.
But at the same time we are saying something different because hitherto,
we had this problem of this.
In other words,
we had the problem of something being part of a structure that is to say God is
imminent in all things.
You know,
human consciousness pervades everything that it encounters.
In other words,
something which is part of a structured but which is at the same time outside of
it,
God creates the world.
And then sort of as Milton says himself,
uncircled stride withdraws,
right?
God is not there.
God is the jerk.
Cachet is the hidden God.
Ah,
who's absent from the world,
uh,
is in effect the structure of the world.
Same thing can be said of men.
You know,
man brings the sense of what the world is into being and then stands aside and
somehow sort of takes it in,
uh,
through,
an aesthetic register or in some other remote way language doesn't do that.
Language is perpetually immersed in itself.
There it does.
Claiming that language is different in the sense that it makes no sense to talk
about it as standing outside of what's going on.
And this is an essential part of the critique of structuralism language is not
other than speech.
It is perpetually manifest in speech,
right.
That it's,
it's,
it's simply a distinction that can't be maintained,
which is why he calls it an event.
In other words,
something of significance has happened Mr. Jones.
And that is language,
right.
All right.
So,
okay.
I suppose in the time remaining and last,
there isn't a lot of it.
Uh,
we'd better ask what language is.
We've,
we've,
we've talked about it.
Uh,
we've had a great deal to do.
Of course we still have the flight Astonia what it is soon.
We'll know.
First of all,
first of all,
I'd better say we'd better say as is already clear from what we've been quoting,
language is not quite so Syrian at is to say it isn't,
it is not a system of signs understood as stable relationships between a concept
world and a world of signifying.
It is not.
In other words,
uh,
it is,
it is not,
um,
a world in which language can be understood as somehow or another a means of
expressing thought.
Deconstruction calls into question,
the distinction between language and thought in calling into question,
the distinction between signifier and signified.
So it's not quite so serious,
even though as Derrida says,
uh,
it can't do without a area and vocabulary.
Another problem is,
uh,
and also also related to the critique of,
so serve as that this idea that what's inward,
what is essential is something that can be voiced and should be voiced.
So that if I think a sign is a way of talking about the expression of a thought,
notice that I call if I'm so sir,
that expression,
a sound image.
In other words,
language according to Derrida in the social area and tradition seems to
privilege,
sound over script over over what is graphic,
why in other words should and,
and he claims that this is a,
a hib hidden bias and the whole history of metaphysics.
Why,
in other words,
should we think of language as speech,
as voice?
Why do we think of voice in the sense of the divine logos?
The word right in the beginning was the word.
Why do we think of voice as a kind of fully present simultaneity that is
absolutely present precisely in consciousness or wherever it is that we
understand language to derive from what's so special about voice?
Why do they say all these terrible things about writing?
Writing is no different from Voight's.
Voice two is articulated combinatorially in time.
Voice too can be understood as inscribed on the ear that it's at.
This is,
this is a metaphor,
but Derrida frequently ISS as a kind of writing on the ear and the distinction
which Derrida takes to be metaphysical,
that so Sarah wants to make between something primary,
something immediate and under riveted voice and something merely a repetitious,
merely reproductive,
merely a handmaiden to voice,
namely writing needs to be called into,
into question.
Now,
this is the point at which we need to say something about,
uh,
about a number of key terms that Derrida uses to sustain this sort of criticism
of traditional ideas of language.
The first,
the first has to do with this notion of supplementary.
A supplement he points out is something that either complete something that
isn't complete or adds to something that already is complete.
I take vitamin C.
Well,
I've,
I also drink a lot of orange juice.
So I,
you know,
I've got fun of vitamin C,
so if I take a vitamin C pill,
I am supplementing something that's already complete.
But if I don't drink any orange juice,
then of course if I take a vitamin C pill,
it's,
I'm supplementing something that's not complete.
But we always call it a supplement and there and we and we can't and it's very
difficult even to keep in mind that conceptual difference between these two
sorts of supplements.
Now a,
a sign traditionally understood is self sufficient,
self contained.
So Sarah has made it a scientific object by saying that it's both arbitrary and
differential,
but assign,
understood under the critique of deconstruction is something that is perpetually
proliferating,
signification,
something that doesn't stand still,
something that can't be understood as self sufficient,
independent in its,
in its nature as being both arbitrary and differential.
It is a bleeding or spilling into successive signs,
uh,
in such a way that it perpetually leaves what buried our calls traces.
That is to say as we examine the unfolding of a speech act,
we see the way in which successive signs are contaminated.
That's not meant to be a bad word,
but influenced one might say in the sense of open the window and influenza,
uh,
influenced by those,
by those signs that preceded.
And so supplement Harrity is a way of understanding the simultaneously living
linear and ever proliferating,
ever self complicated nature of verbal expression.
Now defend loss,
uh,
is a way of talking about,
among other things of talking about the difference between voice and writing.
There is a difference between voice and writing.
Even though they have so much in common voice and rate or writing by the way are
not a stable binary.
There are no stable binary's and Derrida.
Uh,
the difference between voice and writing is that writing can give us all kinds
of indication of difference.
That voice can't give us that part of the interest of misspelling the fellows as
Derrida insists on doing is that we can't,
as in terms of voice as sound tell the difference between different loss and
[inaudible].
Actually one can slightly,
but it's not a difficult,
uh,
different,
difference worth lingering over different loss.
In other words,
with it,
substitution of the A and remember the riff in the essay de Faire,
hos on a,
as a pyramid,
as Alpha,
as origin,
as killing the king because the king remember is the transcendental signified
God.
Man.
And so forth.
All the riff on the riff on,
on the AE in diva Ross as all of those things is something that we can only pick
up if we understand language as writing.
Because in speech,
these modes of difference don't register.
The other aunts is simply the so Syrian linguistic system,
a system of differences understood as spatial.
That is to say,
understood as available to us,
um,
uh,
in as,
as a kind of Smorgasbord,
uh,
as we stand in front of it,
defect Ross introduces the idea of deferral and reminds us that difference.
That is to say our understanding of difference,
our means of negotiating differences,
not something that's actually done in space.
It's done in time.
When I perceive a difference,
I perceive it temporarily.
I do not understand the,
the,
the relation among signs as a simultaneity.
I want to,
if I want to pin it down scientifically,
but in actual,
in the actual,
as Joyce would say,
stream of consciousness.
I understand difference temporarily.
I Diefer difference.
I unfold,
I successively negotiate difference.
And in doing that,
I need the concept of difference.
All right.
Time to go.
I the,
uh,
there are a number of,
there are a couple of things that I want to say about the key moves,
uh,
of Derrida.
Um,
I will,
I will mention those next time.
I'll also look over my notes and see what I might say further about these
troublesome terms,
uh,
and their relation to dairy does understanding of language.
Uh,
so that Tuesday,
uh,
our introduction,
we'll still have to do with Derrida and then we'll move into thinking about
demand.